la adhesión de Suecia a la otan la
crisis energética o la inseguridad son
los temas de conversación en las calles
suecas el día previo a las elecciones
legislativas unos comicios que se
anticipan muy reñidos con los
ultraderechistas demócratas de Suecia SD
en pleno auge de popularidad
entre otras cosas los impuestos más
bajos y los precios de la energía
si bien lo socialdemócratas liderados
por la actual primera ministra Magdalena
Anderson encabezan las encuestas y
parecen estar abocados a la reelección
la incógnita es si la extrema derecha
quedará como líder de la oposición un
hecho que sería sin precedentes el
partido socialdemócrata lleva en el
poder desde 2014 pero su popularidad se
ha debilitado y depende de otros
partidos afines para aprobar leyes
hay mucha gente decente con buenos
valores que votan los demócratas suecos
y creo que están de por cómo se ha
desarrollado las cosas la primera manera
de convencerlos es por supuesto Mostrar
que lo socialdemócratas somos un partido
para la gente corriente para los
trabajadores
en cuanto al calentamiento global fue un
tema prácticamente ignorado en la
campaña electoral por eso la Popular
activista sueca greta thumberg llamó a
protestar para visibilizar la
problemática la crisis climática ha sido
más o menos ignorada en esta campaña
electoral en el mejor de los casos se
han reducido a una cuestión sobre la
energía tenemos mucho que hacer
el próximo ganador gobernará por un
periodo de cuatro años para Acceder al
parlamento unicameral los partidos deben
reunir un mínimo de 4% de los votos
siendo el presidente el que nombra al
candidato a Primer Ministro que cree
tiene más posibilidades de recibir el
apoyo del parlamento y los diputados